viviendo en Argentina
consumiendo bienes y servicios en el
país era difícil esperar un
comportamiento diferente de la inflación
pero este número del 8,4% de inflación
mensual Para abril no deja de ser
impactantes el más alto mensual desde
abril de 2002 más de un 108% de
inflación anual en el mes de abril
también la inflación en alimentos por
ejemplo que es clave porque afecta a los
sectores más pobres Fue de más del 10% y
todo esto además condiciona las
decisiones de los actores económicos en
un escenario de Gran incertidumbre
alimentado también por un contexto de
año electoral en el que el país elegirá
un nuevo presidente Mientras tanto el
ministro de economía Sergio massa se
espera que durante el fin de semana
anuncie medidas para contener la
inflación hay que ver qué ocurre
anteriores medidas que se han tomado no
han logrado frenar la escalada
inflacionaria veremos si en esta ocasión
las medidas que vaya a anunciar
finalmente tienen efecto